oh my god you look amazing thank you i
mean this is sort of unfair you're a
little bit
pros on the red carpet on their first
one tonight
so this is my first i'm not a pro i will
say i'm not a pro
i love this event because it's
celebrities it's uh
actors athletes talk stars who you guys
are both looking forward to seeing
you know there's a lot that's gone on
this year in sports and we're just
excited to be here to celebrate that
uh i'm actually gonna be on the lookout
for chad johnson because he's been
ducking me
we got a fight that that i need to pick
with him and uh and hopefully we can
squash that tonight
tonight's the night to do that it could
be no is this
like a date night for you guys you know
this is probably one of the fancier date
nights we've had
usually it's um a low-key spot getting
pasta or pizza or something around the
city so i think this uh this is one of
the more fancier ones we've had and
what's your plan to celebrate tonight
what do you have fun rest of the weekend
um actually
i'm about to go out to the virgin
islands so i'm excited about that but i
will say
um i'm probably the most unathletic
person so i'm just
very very thankful and excited to be
around such talented people tonight so
i'm just gonna ask for you can you play
sports in high school what was your
first introduction to language sports
i think you should answer that i'm not
uh you know i played i played football
basketball and i ran cross country and
track in high school and then i played
football in college too but
i've lived vicariously through a lot of
my friends who are still playing
professionally so
being around some of their teammates and
again what a good weekend for sports we
got the fight tonight
we've got some big games tomorrow so uh
i couldn't
think of a better place to be to
celebrate tonight i know sports for you
i you know i will say gymnastics as a
child and then
cheerleading and i would consider those
very very difficult sports
but um that's pretty much it for me are
you a good speller because spelling bee
champs are here too
oh really i i feel like i'm not a good
speller as well
yeah i'm probably the worst speller here
so i might need to find her
she's amazing did you get to meet her
she's awesome i saw her i saw her
basketball highlight she's a bucket
she's that's what i said
next time i talk to you we're gonna be
talking about basketball yeah i might
need to get a gaming with her so
as long as it's not horse you know we're
[Music]
good